Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是玛丽安（Marianne）。在深入今天的节目之前，我想快速和大家分享一件目前正在发生的激动人心的事。如果你曾经想过如何创造源源不断的被动收入，而不是没完没了地用时间换取金钱，那么你一定会喜欢由我的商业导师丽莎·约翰逊（Lisa Johnson）主持的“通往持续收入挑战赛”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战赛旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入流。无论你是有志成为心理学家的人、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. Coming up on today's episode of the Aspiring Psychologist podcast, I am joined by a
这些原则同样适用于你。挑战赛中还有由丽莎本人亲自送出的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，你将有机会赢得与我——玛丽安·特伦特（Marianne Trent）博士一对一辅导一小时的机会。想了解更多吗？你当然想。快去我的Linktree（Dr. Marianne Trent），或者查看我的社交媒体频道，或者给我发个简短的私信，我会把所有详情发给你。好了，让我们继续今天的节目。在今天的《有志心理学家播客》（Aspiring Psychologist podcast）中，我请到了一位
qualified clinical psychologist, Dr. Rachel Lee, and we are discussing changing degrees. We are talking about trauma and EMDR, treatment for trauma. And we are also thinking about what the heck executive and non-executive roles are, which you might well hear banded about either in business or in psychology. Hope you find it so useful. Do stay tuned right to the end to hear Dr. Rachel's top tips for reducing burnout. If you're looking to become a psychologist Then let this be your guide With this podcast at your side You'll be on your way to being qualified It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast
合格的临床心理学家雷切尔·李（Dr. Rachel Lee）博士，我们正在讨论转换专业的问题。我们讨论了创伤以及EMDR（眼动脱敏再加工疗法），也就是创伤的治疗。我们还探讨了商业或心理学中经常听到的“执行董事”（executive）和“非执行董事”（non-executive）角色到底是个什么鬼。希望你会觉得这期节目非常有用。请务必收听至节目最后，听听雷切尔博士关于减少职业倦怠的顶级建议。如果你想成为一名心理学家，就让这成为你的指南。有这个播客伴你左右，你将迈向合格的专业人士。这就是《有志心理学家播客》
With Dr. Marianne Trent. I'm a qualified clinical psychologist. So we are now underway with the application season for clinical psychology via the Clearinghouse. I also know that by the time you listen to this episode that the applications for training as an educational psychologist will have opened. So they're due to open on Wednesday the 13th of September at midday. The deadline for references to be submitted needs to be Tuesday, the 14th of November at 5pm. And the application season closes for educational psychology trainee wannabes on Wednesday, the 15th of November at 5pm. So it's a slightly shorter application season than for clinical psychology. But I am aware that's fast coming up.
主持人是玛丽安·特伦特博士。我是一名合格的临床心理学家。目前，我们正通过清算所（Clearinghouse）进行临床心理学的申请季。我也知道，当你听到这期节目时，教育心理学培训的申请通道已经开启。它们将于9月13日星期三中午开放。提交推荐信的截止日期是11月14日星期二下午5点。有志于成为教育心理学实习生的人的申请截止日期是11月15日星期三下午5点。因此，它的申请季比临床心理学稍微短一些。但我知道这很快就要到了。
So, yeah, do get those dates in your diary if that's something that seems like it's going to be important to you in the near future. And that has just made me realize that I might well see if we can get somebody from the AEP to come and talk to us on the podcast. So I might well slip a little message into their inbox shortly so that we can learn a bit more about training as an educational psychologist. So today I am joined by a guest and we're talking about so many brilliant things. It's a qualified clinical psychologist and I so enjoyed our chat. It's going to be a slightly longer episode. It's about 50 minutes long. Don't forget, if you'd welcome any more advice
所以，是的，如果这对你在不久的将来很重要，请务必把这些日期记在日程表上。这也让我意识到，我或许可以看看能否邀请教育心理学协会（AEP）的人来我们的播客做客。我很快可能会给他们的收件箱发个小消息，以便我们能更多地了解如何接受教育心理学培训。所以今天我请来了一位嘉宾，我们聊了很多精彩的内容。她是一位合格的临床心理学家，我非常享受我们的交谈。这将是一集稍微长一点的节目，大约50分钟。别忘了，如果你在这段职业生涯中需要更多建议
or support during this time of your career, come and check out the Aspiring Psychologist community. And don't forget, there's the Asp the aspiring psychologist membership available too I will look forward to catching up with you on the other side I hope you find this episode so useful energizing and helpful I want to welcome our guest along today Dr Rachel Lee who's a clinical psychologist associate non-executive director we'll hear a bit more about what that is later. And also is the owner of North Star Psychology, which is a specialist trauma provision. Is that right, Rachel? I've got that right.
或支持，欢迎加入“有志心理学家社群”。别忘了，还有“有志心理学家会员专区”供你加入。我期待在节目另一端与大家交流。希望你觉得这期节目非常有用、充满活力且有帮助。今天，我想欢迎我们的嘉宾雷切尔·李博士，她是一位临床心理学家、副非执行董事——我们稍后会详细了解这是什么。她也是北方之星心理学（North Star Psychology）的老板，这是一个专注于创伤治疗的机构。是这样吗，雷切尔？我没说错吧。
Thank you, Marianne. It's great to be here. Brilliant. Thank you, Rachel. So one of the reasons I wanted to invite you on the podcast is because you'd actually started one particular course at your undergraduate degree and then after a year you'd then change to psychology and I think that's such an interesting conversation to have because sometimes people can feel you can get that kind of sunk cost fallacy that you think I better keep on doing what I'm doing because what will people say or you know what will it look like could you tell us a little bit about what you were doing, how and how you reached those decisions, if that's OK, Rachel?
谢谢你，玛丽安。很高兴来到这里。太棒了，谢谢你，雷切尔。我想邀请你上播客的原因之一是，你本科时其实先读了一个特定的专业，然后一年后转到了心理学。我觉得这是一个非常有趣的讨论话题，因为有时人们会陷入“沉没成本谬误”，认为自己最好继续做正在做的事，因为别人会怎么说，或者你知道，这看起来会怎么样。雷切尔，如果你觉得可以的话，能跟我们讲讲你当时在做什么，以及你是如何做出这些决定的吗？
Absolutely. So I started at university doing engineering. It was a general engineering course and I was planning to specialise in chemical engineering in the fourth year. And this had been a goal of mine for probably at that point about eight to nine years you know I'd always wanted to be an engineer I'm somebody who's really loves being outside and I like doing things and I like being active and from quite an early age I decided that I wanted to go into engineering I've always really liked the sciences so you know I had to speak to the headmistress to choose the right so because I wanted to choose certain subjects and drop other subjects in order to pursue this career in engineering
当然可以。我大学刚开始读的是工程学。那是一个综合工程课程，我原本计划在第四年专攻化学工程。当时这大概已经成了我八到九年来的一个目标，你知道，我一直想成为一名工程师。我是一个非常喜欢户外活动、喜欢动手做事、喜欢保持活力的人，我很早就决定要从事工程学。我一直非常喜欢理科，所以你知道，为了选择特定的科目并放弃其他科目以便追求工程学职业，我不得不去找校长谈话
and then I got to university and I did enjoy doing the engineering but I found that it wasn't quite what I was sort of looking for I think at, at that time. And I think what happens, you know, in those late years of adolescence is obviously our brain's still changing, isn't it? And we're changing and we meet new people. And I had a few friends who were doing psychology and it just sounded really interesting. You know, became quite fascinated by why people do what they do, why people behave in certain ways. And at the same time, I think I was finding that engineering was just a bit too rigid for me. I was looking for something that was maybe a bit more flexible, where I could have an opinion on things rather than just sort of solving really very difficult equations. So yes, I sort of completed the first year and then moved across
然后我上了大学，也确实挺喜欢工程学，但我发现在当时的那个阶段，它并不是我真正寻找的东西。我想，在青春期的最后几年会发生这种情况，我们的智力显然还在改变，对吧？我们在变，我们结识了新的人。我有一些朋友在学心理学，听起来真的很有趣。你知道，我开始对人们为什么会这样做、为什么人们会有某些行为产生了浓厚的兴趣。与此同时，我发现工程学对我来说有点太死板了。我在寻找一些可能更具灵活性的东西，在那里我可以对事情有自己的看法，而不仅仅是解决非常困难的方程式。所以是的，我读完了一年级，然后转到了
to experimental psychology. I never looked back, really. It's something that I'm really passionate about. Yeah, I just find psychology fascinating. So perhaps I'm a bit of a nerd in that way, that even if I go for a run, I'll tend to listen to a psychology podcast, you know, having ideas. And yeah, it's just been a really fascinating and interesting career. Lovely. Thank you. And you made it sound quite effortlessly there. You made it sound that you just went from engineering to psychology. And I guess some people might be listening to this thinking, oh, yeah, I am doing a degree that I've just, I just don't feel like it's for me. What is the best way to go about if you want to change courses Rachel
实验心理学。说实话，我从未后悔过。这是我真正充满热情的领域。是的，我只是觉得心理学太迷人了。所以也许我在某种程度上有点书呆子气，甚至当我跑步时，我也倾向于听心理学播客，脑子里还会冒出各种想法。是的，这真的是一段非常迷人且有趣的职业生涯。太好了，谢谢。你把这个过程说得轻描淡写，听起来你就像是从工程学直接转到了心理学。我想有些人听到这里可能会想：“哦，是的，我正在读一个自己觉得根本不适合我的学位。”雷切尔，如果想换专业，最好的方法是什么？
yeah so it's um it's interesting to think back on it Marianne because um you know obviously it's that it's quite a while ago but I think what it was was it was a slow a slow um recognition that this wasn't really making me happy anymore maybe suppose now I think a lot about people's values when I see my clients I'm really focused on their values what sort of person they want to be what sort of life they want to have and I suppose that wasn't really sort of fitting with my values and perhaps my values had changed while I was at university so I think it was a process of finding out about the course that I did want to do so thinking about the different options so first of all it was this
是的，回想起来很有意思，玛丽安，因为很显然那是挺久以前的事了。但我觉得当时的过程是，我慢慢地、慢慢地意识到这已经不再让我快乐了。也许我想，现在当我看到我的客户时，我会很多地考虑他们的价值观，我非常关注他们的价值观，他们想成为什么样的人，他们想过什么样的生活。我想这并没有真正符合我的价值观，也许我在大学期间价值观发生了改变。所以我想这是一个去了解我真正想学的课程的过程——思考不同的选择。首先是
engineering isn't really what I want to do anymore and then looking at those different options speaking to people who were doing the course speaking to the tutors finding out what was possible was it even possible to change I was quite lucky because the engineering course was four years possible to change I was quite lucky because um the engineering course was four years and the psychology course was three years so in terms of I mean back in in our time we we were funded weren't we to do to do our university courses it was um different to now where you pay tuition fees but so so those fees had already been agreed for the four years. So it was quite simple in terms of the sort of finances of it. And, yeah, just sort of had some conversations.
工程学已经不再是我真正想做的了，然后看看那些不同的选择，和正在学这门课的人谈谈，和导师谈谈，了解有哪些可能性。甚至有可能转专业吗？我很幸运，因为工程学课程是四年的，而心理学课程是三年的，所以就……我的意思是，在我们的那个年代，我们上大学是有资助的，对吧？这与现在你需要支付学费不同，但当时那些学费已经商定好了是四年的。所以在财务方面它比较简单。而且，是的，就是进行了一些交谈。
I think if I remember, perhaps I had to have to write an essay. I think there was a little bit of an assessment process to check that I could move across to that course. But, you know, I'm going back quite a few years now. Lovely I think I was actually the second or third cohort of having to pay tuition fees but but it was I think three thousand a year rather than the current sort of up to nine thousand a year so but I actually changed courses as well but I changed courses within the first couple of weeks so I was doing forensic science but they'd sort of let me on with the proviso that I might find the chemistry tricky because I hadn't done
我想如果我没记错的话，我可能得写一篇论文。我觉得有一个小小的评估流程来检查我是否能转入那个专业。不过，你知道，这已经是好几年前的事了。太好了。我想我实际上是第二或第三届需要支付学费的学生，但当时是一年三千英镑，而不是现在那种一年高达九千英镑的情况。不过，我自己也换过专业，但我是在头几周内就换了。我当时学的是法医学，但他们允许我入学的前提是，我可能会觉得化学很难，因为我没有修过
chemistry A level and then I started and for what I thought was going to be all forensic science was actually one hour a week of forensic science and the rest was chemistry and I just was completely swamped and was used to finding things relatively easy and then suddenly found myself at the bottom of the stack and I just thought I can't do this this is completely overwhelming it's not for me I don't even know why I've picked this course um and sort of then went back to psychology but my experiences of changing was that the university because like they sit they see you as a human hopefully but they also see you as money and once you're already there as a student they want to retain you as a student and so they will want to try and work with you to keep you as
化学 A-Level。然后我开始了课程，我以为全部都是法医学的内容，实际上每周只有一个小时是法医学，其余时间全都是化学。我彻底被淹没在里面了。我过去习惯于觉得事情相对容易，但突然之间发现自己落在了底端，我当时就想：“我做不到，这完全让人不知所措，这不适合我，我甚至不知道自己为什么要选这个专业。”然后……就转回了心理学。但我转专业的经历是，大学方面——因为他们把你当作一个人来看待，希望如此，但他们也把你当作资金来源。一旦你已经是这里的学生，他们就希望把你留作学生，所以他们会试图与你合作，把你留作
a student and so that they can keep you know one day have you as an alumni as well and so I guess to anyone listening to this thinking what will people say or will the university be awful to me and tell me off and say you should have picked better and you know it's not like that and actually I found that I then had two sets of friends throughout my cohort because I also had my own forensic science I call it science friends that I'd met for a couple of weeks and then you know it was really nice it kind of enriched and added to my experience rather than detracted from it. Yeah it was a little bit similar for me because if you like in moving to psychology I went into
学生，这样他们（你知道的）以后也能让你成为校友。所以我想对任何听到这里、在想“别人会怎么说”或者“大学会不会对我态度恶劣、责备我并说我当初应该选得更好”的人说，其实并不是这样的。事实上，我发现在整个学年中我有两拨朋友，因为我也有那些只认识了几周的法医学“科学朋友”。然后呢，你知道，这真的很棒，它丰富并增添了我的体验，而不是减损了它。是的，我的经历有点类似，因为如果愿意的话，转入心理学时，我进入了
the year below the year that I'd started off in so I'd got friends who were in my original year and then new friends in the in the year below that year and and also Marianne also found the university to be really supportive because I think they want they want their students to be happy don't they they want them to do courses that they will succeed in and so they were yeah they were very supportive in terms of that move. Yeah and actually as I reflect upon that now one of my very closest friends on my cohort there was four of us that were studying psychology that were thick as thieves she had originally done sociology the year before and had decided to change so she had exactly what you had she had her her older peers who were her own age
比我开始时低一个年级的班级。所以我既有我原本那个年级的同龄朋友，又有低一个年级的新朋友。而且，玛丽安，我也发现大学真的非常支持我，因为我认为他们希望他们的学生快乐，对吧？他们希望学生修读那些能够获得成功的课程，所以他们在转专业这方面非常支持。是的，事实上，当我回想起这件事时，我同届里最好的朋友之一——我们有四个学心理学的人，关系铁得像亲姐妹一样——她前一年原本学的是社会学，后来决定转专业。所以她经历的情况和你完全一样：她有和她同龄的高年级同伴，
and then she had actually everyone all of my friends were a year older than me they'd all taken either a gap year or change courses but yeah so she had that experience of kind of still doing some of the the year two stuff whilst we were doing year one stuff and it worked really well and then we we had more friends to play with you know it was it was quite good it was quite good so how did you what happened next so once you graduated let's skip a little bit of your education did you already know you wanted to be a clinical psychologist at that stage um I think I was certainly really interested in mental health. That was sort of my favourite module that we'd done on the course at university. But I actually left and I moved back to Leeds and I had a job as a research assistant in a rheumatology and rehabilitation research unit.
然后实际上我所有的朋友都比我大一岁，他们要么是Gap Year（间隔年）要么是转过专业。但是的，所以她有那种在我们学大一课程时，还在修一些大二课程的经历，而且效果非常好。然后我们有了更多可以一起玩的朋友，真的挺不错的，挺不错的。那么，你是怎么……接下来发生了什么？一旦你毕业了，让我们略过你的一部分教育经历，你在那个阶段就已经知道自己想成为一名临床心理学家了吗？嗯，我想我肯定对心理健康非常感兴趣。那是我们在大学课程中最喜欢的一个模块。但我其实毕业后搬回了利兹，在风湿病学和康复研究单位找到了一份研究助理的工作。
So it's doing quite mathematical mathematical research sort of looking at outcome measures and how we analyze data and things which perhaps sounds quite dull but it was a fantastic job because it had so much travel involved so I was part of a European study and we went to Australia and I went to Chicago and I went to Copenhagen and different places like that so that was really interesting and then then I think it was in doing that that I started to think actually I really do want to be a clinical psychologist and I applied for a research job down at the Institute of Psychiatry at King's College in London and that was working in the eating disorders research unit so I moved down there and that was really with a view to then sort of applying for clinical
所以那是做相当数学化的研究，有点像看结果指标、我们如何分析数据之类的事情。这听起来可能挺枯燥的，但这是一份棒极了的工作，因为它涉及大量的差旅。我是欧洲一项研究的成员，我们去了澳大利亚、芝加哥、哥本哈根以及其他一些地方，所以真的很有趣。然后，我想正是在做这份工作期间，我开始思考：“其实我真的很想成为一名临床心理学家。”于是我申请了伦敦国王学院精神病学研究所的一份研究工作，那是在进食障碍研究单位工作。所以我搬到了那里，当时的目标确实是为了申请临床
psychology courses. And then you ended up getting on in London is that right? Yeah yeah so the first year I wasn't successful and had a bit of a dilemma as to whether to continue or not and then I was successful in the second year and I was really pleased to get on the course. Brilliant and you know I think sometimes it's not uncommon for people to have that sort of soul searching you know is this for me you know I've been told no perhaps they know something about me that I don't know. Perhaps this isn't the career for me. And I think in the days that you were applying, certainly even when I was applying, you'd get like a little paper form of feedback about why you were not being shortlisted for interview. And I kind of wish they'd do that more now because it just being told no when
心理学课程。然后你最后在伦敦被录取了，是这样吗？对，对，所以第一年我没成功，当时面临着一个继续还是放弃的两难境地；然后在第二年我成功了，我非常高兴能被录取。太棒了。你知道，我觉得有时候人们经历那种灵魂拷问并不是什么罕见的事——“这适合我吗？别人对我说‘不’，也许他们比我更了解我。也许这不适合我的职业。”而且我想在你们申请的那些日子里，当然甚至在我申请的时候，你会收到一张纸质的反馈表，上面写着为什么你没有进入面试短名单。我有点希望他们现在能多做一点这种事，因为当你花了几个月的时间填好一份表格
you've spent months on a form you know that's really hard you know because actually in terms of knowing where to start next year I was told I needed to have more varied clinical experience um so initially more varied clinical experience more more relevant experience and another box. And the next year I applied, I think it just said more varied clinical experience. So then I thought, right, well, I'm going to get a job in a different clinical population then. And so I did. I ended up working in a child and adolescent secure unit. But these days, it just can feel like I don't know why I've been turned down. and so I don't know what to do that's different and that's really hard because you need constructive feedback don't we and I
却被告知“不”的时候，真的很难受，因为对于知道明年该从哪里重新开始来说……我被告知我需要有更多样化的临床经验。最初是需要更多样化的临床经验、更多相关经验，以及另一个要求。第二年我申请时，我想上面只写了“更多样化的临床经验”。于是我想：“好吧，那我得去一个不同的临床人群里找一份工作了。”结果我真的这么做了。我最终去了一个儿童和青少年安全精神病房工作。但现在这个时候，感觉就像是“我不知道为什么被拒绝了，所以我也布知道该做些什么不同的尝试”。这真的很艰难，因为我们需要建设性的反馈，对吧？我
remember that Marianne from um the year when I wasn't successful that actually at that point I don't know if it's changed but at that point they didn't offer any feedback whatsoever um in terms of not getting on and it was really difficult to to know where you need to sort of make some changes and adjustments. And I think for me, in terms of the soul searching about whether I wanted to do it, it wasn't necessarily that I felt that maybe I wasn't the right person for it. It was more that actually, I think it was about sort of, they've been, let's see, they've been about 20, 26. And I was living in a shared house with other people who've sort of had jobs in the city, you know, on this sort of clear trajectory and doing very well, I suppose, financially.
记得那件事，玛丽安。在我没有成功的那个年份，事实上在那时——我不知道现在是否变了——在那时，对于没能被录取这件事，他们不提供任何形式的反馈。要知道自己需要在哪些方面做出改变和调整，真的非常困难。而且我想对我来说，在进行关于我是否想做这件事的灵魂拷问时，倒不一定是我觉得自己可能不是这块料。更多的是关于……让我看看，当时大概26岁吧。我跟其他人合租一栋房子，其他人都在金融城有工作，你知道，有着那种清晰的发展轨迹，而且在经济上过得很不错，我想是的。
And I was looking at sort of going on to a three-year course that was going to, you know, obviously take some time before I was going to have a full-time job. And, you know, it was just, it was more sort of starting to plan that out and to think about how does this fit with other things that I might want to do in my life. But like I said, I'm really pleased that I stuck with it. And it's been the best decision I've ever made. I couldn't be happier with the career that I've chosen. So yeah, it's worth sort of continuing, isn't it? You have to sort of just dig in and keep going and sort of hold on to your values, to what's important to you so that you can keep going through those sort of ups and downs. But I do agree with you.
而我正考虑去读一个三年的课程，这显然需要一段时间才能让我拥有一份全职工作。你知道，这只是……更多的是开始规划这些，并思考这如何与我生活中可能想做的其他事情相契合。但正如我所说，我很高兴我坚持了下来。这是我做过的最好的决定。我对选择的职业再满意不过了。所以，是的，坚持下去是值得的，对吧？你必须咬紧牙关坚持下去，坚守你的价值观，坚守对你重要的事情，这样你才能度过那些起起落落。不过我确实同意你的看法。
So just coming back to that point, I do agree with you that it'd be really helpful to give people feedback. And for me, it doesn't quite fit with us. So it doesn't quite fit with us being psychologists because, you know, we know that for people to, you know, to learn, we need to, we need some feedback, don't we we we need some feedback from our environment from the people around us if we want to change then we need to sort of have some information about what's not working you know what why haven't I got on the course this time like you're saying
所以回到这一点，我确实同意你的看法，如果能给人们提供反馈会非常有帮助。对我而言，这与我们作为心理学者的身份不太符合。因为，你知道，我们知道要让人学习，我们需要反馈，对吧？如果我们想改变，我们需要来自环境、来自周围人的反馈，我们需要一些关于“为什么这次没能进课程”、“为什么我这次没被录取”之类的信息。就像你说的，
oh perhaps I need some more clinical experience or perhaps need some more research experience or maybe it's the way that I'd describe things in my form and just really helpful to get a little bit of feedback. Yeah absolutely I agree and actually I realize I've just remembered that another point in the first application I did was that academic skills need strengthening so at that point I started a master's you know so you can immediately take action to make it different next year but it feels like everybody's just having a shot in the dark like I don't know why I wasn't shortlisted I don't know what to change but yeah it's whether we can think about trying to drip feed anything in systemically so I had a conversation recently with somebody as part of the membership that's
“哦，也许我需要更多临床经验，或者也许我需要更多研究经验，或者也许是因为我在表格中描述事情的方式。”能得到一点点反馈真的非常有帮助。是的，完全同意。事实上，我突然想起，我第一次申请时的另一个扣分点是“学术技能需要加强”，所以当时我开始读硕士了。你知道的，你可以立即采取行动，让第二年有所不同。但感觉现在每个人都像是在盲目开枪——“我不知道为什么我没进入短名单，我不知道该改变什么”。不过，是的，这取决于我们是否可以考虑在系统中尝试逐渐灌输一些东西。我最近和一位会员聊过，她
done a lot of the stuff for contextual admissions, which has come about over the last few years, which is thinking about whether someone has been in the care population at any point and whether they had free school meals, those sort of things, so that we're really looking at the demographics. And so the way it was explained to me was that, you may know this already, Rachel, but the way it was explained to me was that if they're trying to decide between offering somebody a an interview or a place and they score the same then the person with the highest contextual admission score will then be offered that to to kind of try to make it as as fair and equitable as possible so that's my understanding of how those um that information is used so in case people are feeling like I don't really want to fill in that information is used so in case people are feeling like I don't really want to fill in that information it can be useful for you to be as honest as you feel comfortable to be so I've certainly found that very interesting. I think it's it's really interesting incredibly valuable
在“情境招生”（contextual admissions）方面做了很多工作。这是过去几年出现的一个概念，即考虑某人在任何阶段是否曾处于保育（受抚养儿童）人群中，是否吃过免费学校午餐之类的事情，这样我们就能真正审视人口统计数据。向我解释的方式是——你可能已经知道了，雷切尔——向我解释的方式是，如果他们试图在决定给某人面试机会还是录取名额时，两人的得分相同，那么情境招生得分最高的人将获得这个机会。这旨在使其尽可能公平合理。这就是我对这些信息如何被使用的理解。所以，如果人们觉得“我其实不太想填这些信息”，那么尽可能诚实地填写会对你很有用。我当然觉得这非常有趣。
isn't it because no just because people with those contextual factors have had many more hurdles to overcome. And, you know, it's great to see that being taken into account. And we need to widen, don't we? We need to widen, broaden the types of people who are working in psychology. You know, we need people from different backgrounds and with different life experiences and lived experiences to help us sort of grow the profession and be able to work with people in different ways, reflecting the diversity of our service users. Yeah, I absolutely agree. And, you know, I was reflecting on what you were saying about you loving your job and loving your career.
我认为这真的很有趣，极其宝贵，
And, yeah, I absolutely feel the same way myself. And, you know, when you meet somebody that's even considering a psychology career, like it, I just I feel like they're just lit up in a different way. And, you know, if we can get more and more people feeling that way about their profession, about their work, about the work they do. So we're speaking, as I'm sort of fresh back from Galway, I got back from Galway doing a keynote speech for the Irish Psychological Society over the weekend. And I was standing on that stage just thinking, gosh, you know, this is amazing. I am here talking to all these aspiring psychologists because I did a psychology degree and you know that I couldn't be here doing this job and
对吧？因为仅仅因为拥有这些情境因素的人必须克服更多障碍。而且，很高兴看到这一点被纳入考量。我们需要扩大范围，对吧？我们需要扩大、拓宽从事心理学工作的人员类型。你知道，我们需要来自不同背景、拥有不同生活经历和切身经历的人，来帮助我们壮大这个行业，并能够以不同的方式与人们合作，反映出我们服务对象的多样性。是的，我完全同意。而且，你知道，当你在思考你刚才说的关于你热爱自己的工作、热爱自己的职业时，
connecting with people as I was on the stage but also all the clients we work with and we work in quite similar areas so I work in trauma as well but it's the biggest privilege you know helping someone bearing witness to some of the most difficult times of their lives real raw pain and helping them through that and then out the other side to be able to have a different experience of life I just it's never lost on me it's never not humbling it's it's an incredible an incredible role that we do and it's all because we did psychology at uni yeah absolutely marianne um i had the most incredible week last week and a couple of clients that i've been working with for a while was sort of um came to the end of their therapy and you know the life changes just absolutely incredible um one of my clients in particular
是的，我自己也有同感。你知道，当你遇到一个甚至在考虑心理学职业的人时，我觉得他们身上散发着一种完全不同的光芒。而且，你知道，如果我们能让越来越多的人对他们的职业、他们的工作、他们所做的事情有这种感觉的话。所以我们正在交谈……我是刚从高威（Galway）新鲜返回。周末我刚从高威回来，为爱尔兰心理学会发表了一场主题演讲。我站在那个舞台上，脑子里就在想：“天哪，这太棒了。我在这里和所有这些有志心理学家交谈，因为我获得了心理学位。”你知道，如果我没有读心理学，我就不可能来到这里做这份工作，
who I've been seeing online is really interested I wish I'd sort of had you know um to compare how how sort of how how she presented at the start of therapy and how she presented at the end you know we sort of reflected on this just this senseness, you know, the joy that was coming out of her. So she just looked so radiant. You know, this was the end of therapy. She looked radiant. She'd made some big decisions about her job. She was made, she got some big plans for the next year. You know, at the start of therapy, she was really struggling with these really very distressing experiences that she'd had in her life, some in childhood, a couple in adulthood that were really significant and really had incredible consequences for her. And, you know, to do that work, it's been so painful at times, but she's really she really committed to it. And then to see her sort of beaming in the final couple of sessions and, you know, telling me about all these changes that she's made, it was incredible. So yes,
并与人们建立联系，就像我在舞台上那样，还有我们合作的所有客户。我们在非常相似的领域工作——我也在创伤领域工作，但这是最大的特权，你知道，去帮助某人，见证他们生命中最艰难的时刻、真正原始的痛苦，陪伴他们度过难关，然后走向另一端，对生活有全新的体验。我从未对此习以为常，这永远让我感到谦卑。这是一项不可思议的角色，而这一切都因为我们在大学里修读了心理学。是的，完全如此，玛丽安。我上周度过了极其不可思议的一周，有几个我合作了一段时间的客户结束了他们的治疗。你知道，生活中的变化简直难以置信。尤其是我的其中一位客户，
it feels like the best job in the world, doesn't it? When you're helping somebody really heal and recover from those awful life experiences so that they can thrive and flourish and live the life that they want to live. Because I always think sort of living with trauma symptoms, it's like you're going through life with this really heavy backpack on and sort of a good trauma therapy when it's successful, it's like taking that backpack off, isn't it? And suddenly, you know, life feels lighter. You can see it in people, in how they carry themselves, in how they, the facial expressions, but also in the decisions and choices that they make. So, yes, it's wonderful. I love the work. Absolutely. One client described it to me as if literally, you know, when you can have quite rapid, sudden shifts sometimes with EMDR, like within a session. And a client said to me,
我一直在网上为她进行心理治疗。真的很让人感慨，我真希望当时能对比一下她治疗开始时的状态和结束时的状态。我们当时一起回顾了这一点——那种从她身上散发出的纯粹的喜悦。她看起来容光焕发。你知道，这是治疗的尾声。她看起来容光焕发，对自己的工作做出了重大决定，对接下来的一年有了宏伟的计划。而在治疗开始时，她一直在与生活中那些非常痛苦的经历作斗争——有些在童年时期，有两件在成年时期，都非常重大，对她产生了难以置信的影响。而且，你知道，去完成那些工作有时是如此痛苦，但她真的全身心投入了。然后看到她在最后几次会谈中喜笑颜开，告诉我她做出的所有这些改变，这真是不可思议。所以，是的，
well, I feel like I've been carrying around some really heavy shopping bags for seven years. I've just put them down for the first time. And it's like, gosh, that is so powerful, so powerful. But like you say, you just see the changes in people's faces, the way they hold their facial expressions, you know, even the way that their face might be lined or, you know, furrowed or creased. And they look lighter. They look happier. They're just easier to be around. I think they attract different people to them as well because they're not giving out those keep away messages. And I don't know whether you find this, but with all of the client work that I do, I'll be like, okay, let's drop our shoulders. Let's take a breath. And when my clients start to begin to get better, they're like, do you know what happened? I was in an office with my colleague and I started to realize what they needed so I said all right just drop your shoulders just take a breath just take
这感觉像是世界上最好的工作，对吧？当你帮助某人真正治愈并从那些糟糕的生活经历中恢复过来，从而使他们能够繁荣发展、过上他们想过的生活时。因为我总是觉得，带着创伤症状生活，就像是生活背负着一个沉重的背包。而一次成功的、好的创伤治疗，就像是把那个背包卸下来，对吧？突然之间，生活感觉更轻了。你可以从人们身上看到这一点——他们昂首挺胸的姿态、面部表情，还有他们做出的决定和选择。所以，是的，太棒了。我热爱这项工作。完全如此。一位客户曾向我形容，有时通过EMDR（眼动脱敏再加工疗法），你有时会产生相当迅速、突然的转变，甚至在一次会谈中就能发生。一位客户对我说：
a moment and they start to teach the skills that I've taught that to them because they start to notice distress in others now that they're able to notice distress in themselves and I think it's the biggest the biggest gift because it makes you realize you're going to be okay because you've internalized these changes you're going to be all right because it's not you know I think sometimes clients have come to me for treatment because they've like well what I've done with this type of approach before hasn't worked I'm looking for something almost changes me on a cellular level so that I just I'm I've dealt with it I've done and I can move forward and I think certainly with EMDR and the mixture of kind of compassion focused therapy that's what we do you know I'm sort of hoping
“我觉得自己好像背着几个很沉的购物袋背了七年。我刚刚第一次把它们放下来。”当时的感觉是：“天哪，这太有力量了，太有力量了。”但就像你说的，你就是能看到人们脸上的变化，他们保持面部表情的方式，你知道，甚至他们脸上可能出现的纹路、皱纹或折痕。他们看起来更轻松了。他们看起来更快乐了。他们更容易相处了。我觉得他们也会吸引不同的人来到他们身边，因为他们不再散发出那种“请勿靠近”的信息。我不知道你是否也有同感，但在我所有的客户工作中，我都会说：“好吧，让我们放松肩膀。让我们深呼吸。”当我的客户开始好转时，他们会说：“你知道发生什么了吗？我和同事在一个办公室里，我开始意识到他们需要什么，所以我说：‘好了，放松肩膀。深呼吸。花一会儿时间。’”他们开始教我教给他们的技巧，因为他们现在能够注意到别人的痛苦了，正如他们能够注意到自己的痛苦一样。我认为这是最大的礼物，因为它让你意识到你会没事的，因为你已经内化了这些改变。你会没事的，因为这不是……我觉得有时候客户来找我治疗，是因为他们觉得“我以前用这种方法做过，但没用。我在寻找某种能在细胞层面上改变我的东西，好让我彻底处理好它，然后继续前进”。我认为，肯定是通过EMDR以及慈悲焦点疗法（compassion-focused therapy）的结合，我们才做到了这一点。你知道，我对人们抱有的期望是，我希望我再也见不到你了——以最好、最友好的方式，因为我希望你开始成为你自己的治疗师。当然，如果你需要我，我在这里。但你知道，这就是我对人们的期望。我相信这也是你的期望，雷切尔。是的，完全如此。我认为关于EMDR，绝对迷人的一点是，不知何故，它触及了其他疗法往往触及不到的部分。我想如果是创伤焦点CBT（认知行为疗法），我们已经处理了创伤症状。她不再有任何闪回或噩梦，但她仍然在努力去做她想做的一些事情。而我呢，周复一周地为她设定行为实验，试图在这方面帮助她，但我们就是无法取得任何突破。当她走在路上时，她仍然感到害怕。然后，在学习了EMDR之后，她回来对我说：“你想试试这个吗？我们去看看关于那个创伤记忆，是不是还有什么没有解决的事情？”所以我们做了一次加工会谈，从那以后一切都变了。我记得，是的，在下一次会谈中她回来时，她已经能够做那些她以前做不到的事情了——也就是我尝试了大约六次会谈却一直在啃的硬骨头。是的，她换了工作，看起来完全不同了。这真的太着迷了。所以这是我第一次使用EMDR，你可以想象我当时是多么好奇，只想更多更多地使用它。现在它构成了我大部分的工作。上周我在伦敦——哦，不是上周，是前一周在伦敦参加督导师在训培训——是的，就是喜欢了解它、学习它。所以，是的，这是一种非常强有力的
with people I hope I never see you again in the nicest possible way, because I hope that you begin to be your own therapist. And obviously, if you need me, I'm here. But, you know, that's my hope for people. And I'm confident it's yours too, Rachel. Yeah, absolutely. And I think that is something that's absolutely fascinating about EMDR, isn't it? It's somehow it reaches the parts that I think other therapies often trauma-focused CBT with, and we'd addressed the trauma symptoms. She wasn't having any flashbacks or nightmares anymore, but she was still struggling to do some of the things she wanted to do. And I'd been, you know, week after week, setting up behavioral experiments with her, trying to help her with this. And we just couldn't get any shift. She was feeling scared as she walked down a road. And then having learned EMDR, you know, came back and said, do you want to try this? Should we just see if there's anything
疗法，我认为它有时会让人们大吃一惊。所以上周，一位客户回来了，我问她：“这一周你感觉怎么样？我们上周对一个不同的记忆做了一些工作。”她说：“天哪，这太神奇了。那个记忆困扰了我40年，我们对它进行了大约30分钟的加工。”她说：“它再也不困扰我了。”她甚至一直在测试它是否还会引发问题。所以我想，是的，这真的太迷人了，看到这些转变并觉得你真的可以帮助那个人的大脑去完成它一直无法完成的治愈，感觉真好。因为我认为我非常喜欢EMDR的另一个原因是，作为治疗师，我们向后靠，让这个人的大脑沿着它需要去的途径和路线去寻找能够帮助治愈的信息。我认为这非常有价值。确实如此。而且我觉得，当我们意识到自己犯了临床心理学的一个“大罪”——我们还没有解释什么是EMDR时。我们或许应该解释一下，因为有时世界各地的人们都在听这个节目，英语可能有时不是他们的第一语言。所以我能想象他们在想：“什么EMD？”所以如果我们要解释EMDR——眼动脱敏再加工疗法（Eye Movement Desensitization and Reprocessing），一个非常上口的名字，EMDR。它是由一位名叫夏皮罗（Shapiro）女士开发的，她现在已经去世了。雷切尔，你能简明扼要地告诉我们什么是EMDR吗？好的，当然。所以EMDR是一种最初为创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）患者开发的疗法，后来扩展用于帮助患有许多不同困难的人。
that's unresolved about that trauma memory? So we did one processing session and everything just shifted after that point. I seem to remember that, yeah, the next session she came back, she'd been able to do the stuff she'd not been able to do you know the stuff I've been trying to chip away at for about six sessions I think and yeah changed her job looked completely different and it was just fascinating so it was my first experience of using EMDR so you can imagine I was really curious and just wanted to use it more and more and now it's the majority of the work that I do and last week I was in London well not last week the week before in London to do the consultants in training training um and yeah just love learning learning about it so um yeah it's it's a really powerful
因此，我们可以用它来帮助缓解疼痛。我们可以用它来帮助人们克服成瘾或进行某些行为的冲动。我们可以将其用于低自尊——当人们有消极的自我信念时，比如“我不够好”；或者我们可以将其用于各种不同的困难，焦虑也是如此。有一个特殊的“前瞻性方案”（flash forward protocol），当人们有大量预期性焦虑时，这会非常有用。所以它基于……这是一种结构非常严密的疗法。当然，我们希望以灵活和有创意的方式与客户一起使用它。它有许多阶段。大致来说，它作用于过去、现在和未来。所以我们在帮助人们处理过去的记忆、当前的触发因素，我们还在帮助人们规划、准备和应对未来具有挑战性的情况。它基于适应性信息加工模型（adaptive information processing model），简而言之，该模型认为我们都有自我治愈的能力。
therapy and I think it can take people a bit by surprise so last week you know client came back and I was I'd sort of said oh how did you feel you know across the week you know we'd done some work on a on a different memory the week before and she said gosh you know it's just been remarkable that memory's been bothering me for 40 years and we've done about 30 minutes of processing on it and she said it's just not bothering me anymore and she'd actually been trying to test it out whether it did still cause a problem so I think it's yeah it's just fascinating and great to see those shifts and feel like you can really help that person's brain to to do the healing it's not been able to do because I think that's the other thing I really love about EMDR is the way that as therapists we sit back and we let the person's brain sort of go down the avenues and the and the routes that
治疗，而且我认为这会让人有点措手不及，所以上周，你知道，一个客户回来时，我曾说过，哦，你觉得怎么样，你知道，在这一周里，你知道，我们前一周在一段不同的记忆上做了一些工作，她说天哪，你知道，这简直太了不这段记忆已经困扰我40年了，我们只对它进行了大约30分钟的处理，她说它不再困扰我了，她实际上一直在试着测试它是否还会引起问题，所以我认为这，是的，这太神奇了，很高兴看到这些转变，并且觉得自己真的可以帮助那个人的大脑去做它一直无法做到的自我修复，因为我认为这是我真正喜欢EMDR的另一件事，那就是作为治疗师，我们坐下来，让那个人的大脑沿着各种途径和路线去探索
it needs to go to to find that information that's going to help healing I think that's really valuable. It really is and I think when I realized we've sort of fallen into a cardinal psychology sin and we've not explained what emdr is so we should probably because if people listen to this all over the world sometimes and say english might not be their first language as well so i'm imagining them going emd what so emdr if we just explain these eye movement, desensitization, and reprocessing, very catchy name EMDR. And it was developed by a lady called Shapiro, who has since passed away. Could you tell us in a brief sort of nutshell what EMDR is, Rachel? Yeah, sure. So EMDR is a therapy that was developed for people with post-traumatic stress disorder and then since has been expanded to help people with lots of different difficulties.
它需要去寻找能够帮助治愈的信息，我认为这真的很有价值。确实如此，我想当我们意识到我们好像犯了一个主要的心理学罪过，我们还没有解释什么是EMDR，所以我们大概应该解释一下，因为如果世界各地的人都在听这个节目，有时英语可能也不是他们的母语，所以我能想象他们在想EMD什么？所以如果我们解释一下，EMDR就是眼动脱敏再处理，一个非常catchy的名字，EMDR。它是有一位名叫夏皮罗的女士开发的，她现在已经去世了。你能简要地跟我们概括一下什么是EMDR吗，雷切尔？好的，当然。所以EMDR是一种最初为创伤后应激障碍患者开发的疗法，后来扩展到帮助有各种不同困难的人。
So we can use it to help people with pain. We can use it to help people with addictions or urges to engage in certain behaviors we can use it with low self-esteem so when people have got negative self-beliefs things like i'm not good enough or we can use it with with all sorts of different difficulties anxiety as well so there's a particular flash forward protocol that can be really helpful when people are sort of um have got a lot of anticipatory anxiety. So it's based, it's a therapy that is, it's a very structured therapy. Although of course we want to use it in a flexible and creative way with our clients. And it has a number of phases. I guess broadly it works on the past, the present and the future. So we're helping people with their past memories, with their current triggers, and we're helping people to plan and prepare and cope with future challenging situations. And it's based on the adaptive information processing model, which in a nutshell says that we all have a capacity to heal.
所以我们可以用它来帮助缓解疼痛。我们可以用它来帮助人们戒除瘾头或进行某些行为的冲动，我们可以用它来治疗低自尊，所以当人们有消极的自我信念，比如我不够好，或者我们可以用它来治疗各种不同的困难，还有焦虑，所以有一个特别的闪现向前协议，当人们有很多预期性焦虑时，这会非常有用。所以它是基于，它是一种疗法，是一种非常结构化的疗法。当然，我们希望在与客户的合作中以灵活和有创意的方式使用它。它有几个阶段。我想大体上它作用于过去、现在和未来。所以我们帮助人们处理过去的记忆、当前的触发因素，并帮助人们计划、准备和应对未来具有挑战性的情况。它基于适应性信息处理模型，简而言之，该模型认为我们每个人都有治愈的能力。
So just as much as our physical in terms of physical health, we can make a physical recovery. The body knows how to heal a physical wound. So if you cut your arm, you know, unless there's some dirt or some sort of something else in there, your body will heal naturally. So if there is some grit, you know, if you've fallen off your bike, I know you had a fall on your bike, Marianne, and I'm sure we've all sort of had that experience and you get some grit in a cut, then you need to clean it, don't you? You need to remove the grit, clean it, and then the body will heal itself we can also heal from psychological difficulties or from disturbing events that have happened in our life and that are continuing to impact on us in the present so and the way that we do that is by creating the conditions to help that person access the memories of these difficult times whilst also being very mindful that they're in the present,
所以就像我们的身体健康一样，我们也可以实现身体上的康复。身体知道如何治愈身体上的伤口。所以如果你割伤了手臂，你知道的，除非里面有一些灰尘或其他什么东西，否则你的身体会自然愈合。所以如果里面有一些沙砾，你知道的，如果你从自行车上摔下来，我知道你从自行车上摔下来过，玛丽安（Marian），而且我相信我们都经历过那种情况，伤口里弄进了一些沙砾，那么你就需要清洗它，对吧？你需要清除沙砾，清洗伤口，然后身体就会自我疗愈，我们也可以从心理困境或生活中发生的、并继续对我们产生影响的干扰事件中恢复过来。所以我们做到这一点的方法是创造条件，帮助这个人接触这些困难时期的记忆，同时非常注意他们正处于当下，
and then to help the brain to do this processing that it's not been able to do before. So I always think that with EMDR, I always think, you know, the brain is a little bit like a factory, and it turns an experience into a stable long term memory. But when we have very disturbing things happen to us, I think particularly things where we feel, experiences where we feel helpless or powerless or in sort of really intense threat, then that factory shuts down. And instead of the experience being turned into a memory, it's stored in its sort of raw form. And what's fascinating is that when you look at neuroimaging studies, we can actually see
然后帮助大脑进行以前无法完成的信息处理。所以我总是觉得，在EMDR（眼动脱敏再加工）方面，我总是觉得，你知道的，大脑有点像一家工厂，它将经历转化为稳定的长期记忆。但是当我们遇到非常烦扰的事情时，我认为特别是那些让我们感到无助、无力，或者处于真正强烈威胁之中的经历，那么这家工厂就会关闭。这段经历没有被转化为记忆，而是以其原始的形式储存起来。最迷人的是，当你查看神经影像学研究时，我们实际上可以看到
that before and after EMDR, the memory is in a different place. So the neuroimaging studies tell us that the memory is in the limbic system, which is the part of the brain where we do all our complex thinking our reasoning our decision making so essentially i think what happens is in those disturbing experiences we switch into survival mode and that's exactly what we want our brains to tell us to do you know the survival mode is there for a reason to help us to to survive to exist, to get through this difficult situation. So I think it's because we're in that survival mode that that processing isn't happening. Now, of course, sometimes the processing happens after the
在EMDR治疗前后，记忆处于不同的位置。神经影像学研究告诉我们，记忆位于边缘系统，这是大脑中负责所有复杂思考、推理和决策的部分。所以本质上，我认为发生的事情是，在那些烦扰的经历中，我们切换到了生存模式，这正是我们希望大脑告诉我们去做的事情。你知道的，生存模式的存在是有原因的，它可以帮助我们生存、存在、度过这个困难的局面。所以我认为正是因为我们处于生存模式，信息处理才没有发生。当然，有时信息处理会发生在
experience, but sometimes it doesn't or it doesn't happen in its fully. So what EMDR does is it provides an opportunity for the brain to do the healing that it's not been able to do at the time. And we can use it with, you know, sort of very disturbing memories. So, you know, what you might think of as sort of classic trauma, let's say an accident or an assault, something like that. And we can also use it with experiences that are maybe a bit lower on that sort of disturbance scale but have still had a significant impact on us. So I'm thinking about, you know, experiences maybe being humiliated or bullied or, you know, just having a difficult time at times in our lives that might have led us to form some unhelpful conclusions about ourselves that continue to bother us,
经历之后，但有时不会，或者没有完全进行。因此，EMDR所做的是为大脑提供一个机会，去完成当时无法完成的治愈。我们可以用它来处理非常烦扰的记忆。所以，你可能会认为是典型创伤的记忆，比方说事故或袭击，诸如此类的事情。我们还可以用它来处理那些在干扰量表上可能稍低，但对我们仍然产生了重大影响的经历。所以我想到了那些经历，比如被羞辱、被欺凌，或者在生命中的某些时候经历了一段艰难时期，这可能会导致我们对自己得出一些无益的结论，而这些结论一直困扰着我们，
or that might still mean that when we're in certain situations, our emotions get triggered in a way that they, sorry, and we feel the feelings that we felt back at the time. So sometimes, you know, whereas in, I think in PTSD, you know, it's very obvious that that situation is triggering that sort of trauma response. Sometimes what can happen is that people just feel the feelings that they've had earlier in their life. And I think that can be really confusing because, you know, there's no sometimes it might be hard to make that link. But when we look into it, when we're doing our sort of history taking and we're talking to people about their experiences we can often make that link and and i think that can be one of the really powerful things in therapy is to be able to link current experiences to to past experiences
或者可能仍然意味着当我们处于某些情况下时，我们的情绪会被以某种方式触发，对不起，我们会感受到当时那种感觉。所以有时，你看，而在创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）中，我认为这种情况非常明显，那种情况正在触发那种创伤反应。有时发生的情况是，人们只是感受到了他们生活早期时的感受。我认为这可能会非常令人困惑，因为，你知道的，有时很难建立这种联系。但当我们深入研究时，当我们进行病史采集并与人们谈论他们的经历时，我们经常可以建立这种联系。我认为这可能是治疗中非常强大的事情之一，能够将当前的经历与过去的经历联系起来，
and what's happened in that person's life it's a way of making sense of it isn't it and often i think you know no wonder you feel that way in this situation because actually that's very similar to this thing that happened to you in the past but so where EMDR comes in is we can then go into the past and process any parts of that experience that are sort of carrying that emotional charge and so that sort of can then make things feel really different and I think what's fascinating about EMDR is when you've processed the memory, people will say it just feels so different now. It's like, you know, so normally before EMDR, people are bringing that memory to mind. They can feel it in their bodies. There's an emotional charge. And afterwards, it's like all their other memories of course if it's an upsetting experience
以及那个人的生活中发生了什么。这是一种理解它的方式，不是吗？而且通常我认为，难怪你在这种情况下会有这种感觉，因为实际上这与过去发生在你身上的那件事非常相似。所以EMDR介入的地方在于，我们可以回到过去，处理该经历中带有这种情绪电荷的任何部分，这样就可以让事情感觉真的很不一样。我认为EMDR最迷人的地方在于，当你处理了这段记忆后，人们会说现在感觉太不一样了。这就像，你知道的，所以在EMDR之前，人们通常会把那段记忆带入脑海。他们能在身体里感受到它。有一种情绪负荷。而在那之后，它就像所有其他记忆一样，当然，如果这是一次令人沮丧的经历，
it will still feel like a sad memory but the person's not feeling it sort of in their body and that paves the way for them to be able to respond differently in the present sorry i didn't give you the sort of nutshell answer it's quite hard to um to bring it down it was beautiful thank you so much and actually you've raised a really important point there that actually we don't need to be hierarchical about the trauma it doesn't need to feel like it's bad enough and it was making me think that actually I had EMDR for something which to lots of people might have felt like nothing so when my little boy my second child so anyone with two children will relate to this I wanted to make sure that I
它仍然会感觉像是一个悲伤的记忆，但这个人不再会在他们的身体里感受到那种情绪，这为他们在当下做出不同的反应铺平了道路。对不起，我没有给你那种简明扼要的回答，要把它浓缩起来确实挺难的。太美妙了，非常感谢你。实际上你提出了一个非常重要的观点，那就是我们不需要对创伤进行分级，它不需要让人觉得“够严重”才算创伤。这让我想起，实际上我曾因为一件对很多人来说可能觉得微不足道的事情接受过EMDR治疗：当时我的小儿子，我的第二个孩子——家里有两个孩子的任何人都会对此感同身受——我想确保我
was still taking loads of photos and loads of videos of the second child and I am the second child myself so you know there's probably about two photos of me for the first three years of my life so I thought I'm not going to have that happen so I made sure that I bought a new phone so my little boy was born just after my birthday a few days after my birthday so for my birthday I asked for a brand new iPhone so I could make sure there was plenty of room on there for taking loads of photos and loads of videos of the two of them together of me of him of you know just of his earliest moments because it was a brand new phone I thought it's going to be absolutely fine so I remember sitting on my bed probably a couple of months into his birth and it flashed up that my iCloud memory was full. Did I want to buy some additional storage? And I looked at it and it said it was going to be 79p a month.
依然为第二个孩子拍了大量的照片和视频。我自己就是老二，所以你知道的，我人生头三年的照片大概只有两张左右。所以我当时想，我绝不允许这种事情再次发生。于是我特地买了一部新手机。我的小儿子出生在我的生日之后，就在我生日几天后。所以为了我的生日，我要求得到一部崭新的iPhone，这样我就可以确保里面有充足的空间，为他们两个人的合影、我的照片、他的照片、他最初的时刻拍下大量的照片和视频。因为这是一部新手机，我想这下绝对没问题了。我记得自己坐在床边，大约在他出生几个月的时候，手机弹出一个提示说我的iCloud内存满了。我是否想购买额外的存储空间？我看了看，上面说每月只需79便士。
And I thought, you know what? It's a brand new phone. It's going to be fine. And really, because I'm on maternity leave, I probably could do with saving some money. So I remember putting it down on my bed and thinking, no, I'm not going to do that. What I couldn't have known was that my phone would then corrupt a short time after that. And I lost basically everything on my phone. And so I'd lost all of those early, early memories. And I found it really, really hard to forgive myself. And it was really distressing me. But it sounds silly. But it made me feel like I was a terrible mother.
心想，你知道吗？这是一部新手机。应该没问题的。而且说实话，因为我在休产假，我可能确实需要省点钱。所以我记得把它放在床边，心想，不，我不打算这样做。我不可能知道的是，不久之后我的手机就会损坏。基本上我手机里的所有东西都丢失了。所以那些非常非常早期的记忆我全都失去了。我发现自己真的、真的很难原谅自己。这让我感到非常痛苦。听起来可能很傻。但这让我觉得自己是个糟糕的母亲。
And so I had to kind of work through that. And even now, as I talk about that, it makes me feel a bit sad. But I can do it in a way that I've been able to just get on with my life and just think, you know what, you didn't know, you know, the technology let you down. it should have worked it should have been fine it wasn't your fault you don't love your child any less you tried you know it is what it is and and I was able to then get photos from other people that had taken photos of him as well so you know it just makes it lay flat and it helps me assimilate that into your life yeah and I think that's a really great point, Marianne, and, you know, really connected with that experience there as a mom, just so awful. And yeah, so it's a great example of the whole variety of different experiences that we could use EMDR for. And
所以我不得不努力去克服这种情绪。即使现在，当我谈论这件事时，它还是会让我觉得有点难过。但我能够以一种我已经能够继续我的生活的方式来处理它，心里想，你知道吗，你当时并不知道，你知道的，是科技让你失望了。它本该正常工作的，本该没问题的，这不是你的错，你并没有因此少爱你的孩子一点，你已经尽力了，你知道的，事情就是这样。而且我后来还能够从其他人那里收集到他们给他拍的照片。所以，你知道的，这让事情变得平缓了，它帮助我将这段经历融入了我的生活。是的，我认为这是一个非常棒的观点，玛丽安，而且，你知道的，真的与作为一个母亲的那种经历产生了共鸣，真的太糟糕了。所以，是的，这是一个很好的例子，说明了我们可以使用EMDR来处理各种各样不同的经历。而且
also you highlighted that it helps you to assimilate the information and that's how I think about EMDR as well that you know if you think about all your different experiences in life as like dots on a page and also all your knowledge and different perspectives and ideas and learnings that you've had in life as dots on a page. And I think what happens with these kind of disturbing memories is that they're not connected to as many dots as would be helpful. And EMDR helps to create some new connections. So, you know, I guess there you would have had that knowledge that you're a good mum and some knowledge that phones sometimes corrupt
你也强调了它如何帮助你吸收信息，这也是我对EMDR的看法。如果你把生活中的所有不同经历想象成页面上的点，同时也把你在生活中拥有的所有知识、不同的视角、想法和学到的东西想象成页面上的点。我认为这些令人烦扰的记忆所发生的情况是，它们没有与尽可能多的点连接起来，而这本应是有帮助的。EMDR有助于建立一些新的连接。所以，你知道的，我想你当时拥有自己是个好妈妈的知识，以及手机有时会损坏的知识，
and phones that we can't predict everything that's going and some knowledge that we can't predict everything that's going, and some knowledge that we can't predict everything. And then you've got this memory, haven't you, of like, oh, my gosh, you know, I've lost all my photographs. And those things weren't connecting. So I imagine your EMDR helped those connections to be created. Yeah, absolutely. Exactly that. Exactly that. And, you know fine it's all right it's not ideal you know if I could go back and choose to either have not have the phone corrupt or to have the uh you know just to pay 79p a month I would have done that but you know hindsight is 20 20 vision as they say so let's just have a little bit of a think before we finish about what a non-executive director is and why
还有我们无法预测一切正在发生的知识，以及我们无法预测一切的知识。然后你有了这样一段记忆，对吧，哦，天哪，你知道的，我所有的照片都丢了。这些事情当时并没有连接起来。所以我想象你的EMDR帮助建立了这些连接。是的，绝对是这样。完全是这样。而且，你知道的，没关系，这没问题，虽然不太理想，你知道的，如果我能回到过去，选择手机不损坏，或者选择花呃，你知道的，每个月付79便士，我本会那样做的。但正如他们所说，事后诸葛亮总是看得最清楚。所以在我们结束之前，让我们稍微思考一下，什么是“非执行董事”（Non-executive Director），以及为什么
they're important oh great so this is a really new role for me um marianne and um it's it kind of came a little bit out of the blue if i'm honest about it it's not something that i really had thought about doing before or really even, I guess, sort of understood too much about. But I was approached about this role. And the more that I looked into it, the more that I thought it sounded really interesting. And also, it came at just the right time for me. So I left the NHS sort of October, November time last year. and then I've been very focused on developing my psychology service my trauma service I was also very I found it really hard to leave the NHS you know I've always sort of held the NHS sort of close in my heart I think you know I've worked
他们很重要。哦，太棒了，所以这对我和玛丽安来说是一个非常新的角色，嗯，说实话，这有点出乎意料。这不是我以前真正考虑过要做的事情，甚至，我想，我也没有真正太了解它。但我被接洽了这个角色。我了解得越多，就越觉得它听起来非常有趣。而且，它出现的时间对我来说也恰到好处。所以我去年10月、11月左右离开了NHS（英国国家医疗服务体系），
I've worked there for sort of over 20 years and always saw myself as somebody who worked in the NHS. I've never intended to leave. But, you know, it was the right decision to make. And I've been really happy since I left. But I think I still felt that I wanted to do something to contribute, maybe to the NHS or to another organisation in some way. So whilst over the last few months I'd been, sorry, so maybe after leaving the NHS, you know, I did some work with a couple of charities because I felt like, you know, I still wanted to give back, if you like. So an associate, sorry, a non-executive director sits on the board of an organisation. so i'm an associate non-executive director with a large um nhs trust um and so we sit we sit on the board and so you've got the
然后我一直非常专注于发展我的心理学服务和创伤服务。我也非常……我发现离开NHS真的很艰难，你知道的，我一直把NHS放在心里很近的地方，我想，你知道的，我工作了
executive directors these are the people who are paid by the organization so for example you've got obviously chief chief executive but also you know of, well, they're called people offices now, but essentially what was the director of human resources and you have a strategy director and so on. So different directors. And then the non-exec directors are people from outside of the organisation. So these are people who are on the board to offer, I suppose, an objective point of view and to come with some curiosity and to ask some questions in the board meetings to check that things have maybe been looked at from different angles, to be curious about what's happening in the organisation. So as non-executive directors, we're there to really support the board to help the
我在那里工作了二十多年，一直认为自己是一个在NHS工作的人。我从来没有打算离开。但是，你知道的，这是一个正确的决定。自从我离开后，我一直非常快乐。但我认为我仍然觉得我想做点什么来做出贡献，也许是以某种方式对NHS或另一个组织做出贡献。所以虽然在过去的几个月里我一直在，抱歉，所以在离开NHS之后，你知道的，我与几个慈善机构合作过，因为我觉得，你知道的，如果你愿意的话，我仍然想回馈社会。所以，一个副非执行董事（associate non-executive director）在组织的董事会中任职。所以我是一个大型NHS信托基金的副非执行董事。所以我们坐在董事会上，然后你有了
organization to deliver the best service that it can and to do that in the sort of safest way possible and I suppose that's by sort of sometimes being a bit of a critical friend my role as an associate non-executive director so this is a new role within the trust and they've not had an Fy rôl fel Rheolwr Nid-gylchredol Ymgyrchol. Felly, dyma rôl newydd o fewn y trws. Nid oedd ganddo Rheolwr Nid-gylchredol Ymgyrchol yn ôl. Ac mae wedi bod yn rôl cyfrwng mawr ar draws y GIG i gyfrwng Rheolwr Nid-gylchredol Ymgyrchol. Felly, dyma rôl newydd a fyddai'n bwysig i rai o'ch gwrandoeidwyr. Oherwydd y trws rwy'n ei wneud yn ystod hyn, roeddent yn ddiddorol iawn i gael clinisiann ar eu bwrdd, interesting to some of your listeners because the trust that I'm doing this in they were really interested keen to have a clinician on their board recognising that this is a mental health trust and that it would be helpful to have a perspective a clinician's perspective
执行董事。这些人是由组织支付薪酬的人，例如，你显然有首席执行官，还有，你知道的，嗯，他们现在被称为人事官员，但本质上就是以前的人力资源总监，你还有战略总监等等。不同的董事。然后非执行董事是来自组织外部的人。这些人进入董事会是为了提供，我猜，一个客观的观点，带着一些好奇心，在董事会会议上提出一些问题，以检查事情是否从不同的角度得到了审视，对组织中发生的事情保持好奇。因此，作为非执行董事，我们真诚地支持董事会，帮助组织提供其能力范围内最好的服务，并以尽可能最安全的方式做到这一点。我想这有时是通过扮演一个有点像“批评性的朋友”（critical friend）的角色来实现的。我作为副非执行董事的角色，所以这是信托基金内的一个新角色，他们以前没有（威尔士语插话，内容大意为信托基金很高兴能有临床医生加入他们的董事会），因为这是一个心理健康信托基金，有临床医生的视角会很有帮助。
so I found this very interesting because having worked in the trust for 15 years having sort of led services and supervised colleagues and obviously seen a lot of service users as well, I felt that I was in a good position to perhaps be an advocate for staff members as well as for service users. And I suppose as well, since I've left the NHS, then growing my own business gives me that other perspective as well on sort of strategy and, you know, sort of what's important in terms of growing a business and, you know, being more aware of sort of how things work in the corporate world, I suppose, is what I'm thinking there. So the associate non-executive director role I see as a little bit like an apprenticeship to becoming a non-executive director.
所以我觉得这非常有趣，因为在这个信托基金工作了15年，领导过服务，监督过同事，显然也见过很多服务使用者，我觉得自己处于一个很好的位置，不仅可以为服务使用者代言，也可以为员工代言。我想也是，自从我离开NHS以来，发展我自己的业务也为我提供了另一个视角，关于战略，以及在发展业务方面什么是重要的，更了解企业世界是如何运作的，我想我当时是这么想的。所以我认为副非执行董事的角色有点像成为非执行董事的学徒。
So the NHS has created these roles so that people who've not had experience of being a non-executive director can move into those positions. So this is a two year post. It is a paid post. We were talking earlier, weren't we, about how it's a bit similar to being a school governor. But the benefit here is that you are being paid. It's a role that I do sort of two to three days a month. So we have a board meeting once a month, that's a full day. And it's really very interesting, you know, to go back into an organisation at such a different level, to understand all the different sort of challenges and opportunities within the organisation organization to see the sort of decisions that have been made to work with a whole different array of people as well is really fascinating and so we have the board meeting and then we have the non-executive directors meetings
因此，NHS创造了这些角色，以便没有担任非执行董事经验的人可以进入这些职位。所以这是一个为期两年的岗位。这是一份带薪的岗位。我们之前讨论过，不是吗，它有点类似于学校校董（school governor）。但这里的好处是你有薪水。这是一个我一个月花两到三天时间的角色。所以我们一个月开一次董事会，那是一整天。以如此不同的层面重新进入一个组织，了解组织内的所有不同挑战和机遇，看到所做出的决策，与形形色色的人合作，这真的非常非常有趣。所以我们有董事会会议，然后我们有非执行董事会议，
and then I'm just in the process of joining a couple of committees as well. So I'm going to be on the collaborative committee. But I'm also sort of spending some time going to each of the different committees in the trust so that I can really understand how everything works. So, yes, so far I've found it very, very interesting. And it's been, you know, it's been very very the team's been very welcoming so um it it feels very different to to doing the clinical work and i think that's something for me as thinking about you know you're in quite you need to be in quite a different mindset when you go into into the board meeting or rather to sort of recognize that you're not
然后我正处于加入几个委员会的过程中。所以我将加入合作委员会（collaborative committee）。但我也花时间参加信托基金中的每一个不同的委员会，这样我才能真正了解一切是如何运作的。所以，是的，到目前为止，我发现它非常非常有趣。而且，你知道的，团队非常热情。所以，这感觉与做临床工作非常不同。我认为对我来说，这也是需要思考的一点，当你进入董事会会议时，你需要保持一种非常不同的心态，或者更确切地说，是要认识到你不是
going in as a psychologist you're going in as a associate non-executive director although of course you know I'm there to be a psychologist as well so so it's sort of yeah I think I'm finding my way really to think about how those two things come together. Yeah and I think it sounds like such fascinating work but also is further demonstrating the real flexibility and diversity of our career and where it can take us. And that, you know, you never know when something really energising and really exciting might crop up for you that, you know, that you can get involved with and that you continue to grow you continue to learn you continue to change and I think it's just wonderful you know I think if anyone if anyone's listening to this feeling like they're stagnating in their career there's you know there's opportunities everywhere and you know like like you said I did do school governance for a couple of years and I learned so much there
以心理学家的身份进去的，你是以副非执行董事的身份进去的，尽管当然，你知道的，我也是去当心理学家的。所以这有点，是的，我想我正在摸索如何将这两件事结合起来。是的，听起来这是一项非常迷人的工作，同时也进一步证明了我们职业真正的灵活性和多样性，以及它能把我们带向何方。而且，你知道的，你永远不知道什么时候会有真正充满活力和令人兴奋的事情突然出现，让你参与其中，让你继续成长，继续学习，继续改变。我认为这太棒了，你知道的，我认为如果任何人听到这个节目，觉得自己的职业生涯正在停滞不前，你知道的，机会无处不在。你知道的，就像你说的，我确实做了几年学校校董，我在那里学到了很多关于战略、如何具有战略眼光、如何使用建设性的反馈和批评的知识。你知道的，有很多方法可以让我们重新激活我们的技能，帮助我们感觉不同，同时也对服务有用且有益。所以谢谢你，这真的很有趣，因为我认为甚至自我作为助理心理学家工作时，以及自我获得资历工作时，我其实并不太明白董事局成员都在做什么。所以我想这真的很实用，能对那个领域有一个“墙头草”般的内部洞察，所以谢谢你。在结束之前，瑞秋，你能给我们的 listeners（听众）一些建议，告诉他们在追求心理学世界的旅程中如何试图减少职业倦怠吗？是的，绝对可以。
about strategy about being strategic about how to use constructive feedback and criticism you know there's so many ways that we can liven up our skills and help us to just feel differently but also be useful and and you know beneficial to services so thank you that's really interesting because I think even when I was working as an assistant and when I was working as qualified I didn't really get what directors did so I think that's really useful to have a little bit of a fly on the wall insight into that so thank you just before we finish Rachel could you give our listeners any advice for trying to reduce burnout on their journey in aspiring psychology world? Yeah, absolutely.
因此，我认为在职业生涯的不同阶段感到某种程度的倦怠是很自然的。我发现非常有用并会鼓励他们去做的事情之一，就是真正发展他们身上那部分不属于心理学家的自己，如果你愿意这么说的话。这让我想起了我在NHS服务机构工作的一段时光，当时我感到有点挣扎，我迷上了攀岩，去利兹一个很棒的室内攀岩馆。当时我住在利兹市中心，下班后几乎每天晚上都会去这个攀岩馆，我非常喜欢它。我喜欢解决问题以及其中的肾上腺素飙升，这确实为我创造了一种极好的方式来切换心情。如果你想想
So I think it's natural to feel some feelings of burnout at different times in our careers. And one of the things that I've found really helpful and that I would encourage them to do is to really develop that other part of themselves that's that's not the psychologist if you like so it takes me back to a time when I was working in a NHS service and I think struggling a bit and I got really into rock climbing um into you know going to there's a great climbing indoor climbing world in Leeds and I was living in central Leeds at the time and I would go to this climbing wall most nights after work and I loved it I loved sort of solving the problems and the adrenaline of it and that really created a brilliant way for me to switch off if you think
正念（mindfulness），它其实就是关于活在当下，对吧？所以在攀岩墙上，你知道的，你必须活在当下，否则你可能会掉下来，或者你无法完成下一个动作，或者无法解决问题。但这也是关于找到真正符合你价值观的事情，我认为。所以去思考，你知道的，这样工作就不会成为你正在做的全部事情。我认为当我们真正投入时，这种情况很容易发生，当然大多数医疗保健专业人员都是如此，我们真的想做好工作，并且往往愿意投入那些额外的时间。腾出时间做一些对你来说很重要的事，我会说它
about mindfulness it's really about sort of being present isn't it so when you're on the climbing wall you know you have to be present or you're probably going to fall off or you're not going to manage to to make the next move or to solve the problem but also it's about finding something that really fits with your values I think so thinking yeah you know so that so that work doesn't become everything that you're doing and I think it can be easy for for that to happen when we're you know really committed and of course most health care professionals are we really want to do a good job and we'll be willing often to put in those extra hours and making some time to do some stuff that that sort of is important to you and i would say it
也能给你提供一个来自心理学的心理休息。所以我想，你知道的，做一些感觉真的很不一样、符合你的价值观的事情（也许你稍微挑战了自己一点，所以这是一项你可以真正沉浸其中、投入其中的活动，引导你走上另一条道路），这是第一件事。然后第二件事，现在我做不到了，带着两个孩子去攀岩没那么容易，还有他们所有的活动（你知道的，花很多时间在汽车里开车，坐在停车场里），但现在我做的另一件事是，我只是尽量多地融入大自然，我发现这真的很舒缓。所以，出去跑步或散步，去美丽的地方，只是真正享受那种时光。所以，是的，这是我的两个
also gives you that mental break from psychology so i think you know doing something that feels really different fits with your um values you know maybe you're stretching yourself a little bit so something where you can really get absorbed in that activity get engaged in it sort of um be taking yourself down another path so that's one thing and then the other thing that that I do now I've not it's not so easy to go climbing um with two children and um you know all their activities you know spend a lot of time sort of driving around in cars and sitting in car parks but um but the other thing that I do now is I just try and get into nature as much as I can and I find that that's really soothing so um getting out for a run or a walk you know going to beautiful places um and just sort of really enjoying enjoying that time so so yeah they'd be my my two um
首选的自我照顾策略吧。如此精彩的建议，非常感谢你，也谢谢你花时间与我们交谈，探讨如此重要的领域。我从我们的对话中真的收获良多，我知道我们的听众也会如此。瑞秋，如果我们的听众想了解更多关于你的信息，与你联系，并了解更多关于你的工作，他们该怎么做呢？在哪里能最好地找到你？我在所有常见的社交媒体平台上都有账号。
go-to sort of self-care strategies i suppose such brilliant advice and thank you so much and thank you for spending your time and talking to us about such important areas. So I've really taken so much from our conversation and I know our listeners will as well. So how can our listeners learn more about you and connect with you and learn more about your work if they want to, Rachel? Where's the best place to find you? So I'm on all the usual social media platforms.
我有推特动态，账号是DrRachelLee。在Instagram上，我是Northstar Psychology。在LinkedIn上，我是Dr Rachel Lee。我还有一个网站，northstarpsychology.co.uk。我喜欢与其他人、其他心理学家建立联系。分享心理学观点和知识并倾听其他人的观点真是太棒了。我们最近发表了一篇论文，是关于在治疗中使用照片的，我想这可能会让你们的听众感兴趣，因为当我担任一个照片之声（photo voice研究项目的指导委员会成员时，我对这个领域产生了浓厚兴趣。参与其中的参与者，抱歉，参加了
I've got a Twitter feed, which is DrRachelLee. On Instagram, I'm'n Northstar Psychology. Yn LinkedIn, rwy'n Dr Rachel Lee. Ac mae gen i wefan, northstarpsychology.co.uk. Rwy'n hoffi cysylltu â phobl o seicolegwyr eraill. Mae'n wych rhannu syniadau seicolegol a gwybodaeth a gweld persbectifau pobl eraill. Mae'r llyfr ddiweddarol rydyn ni wedi'i gyhoeddi, sy'n ymwneud â defnyddio ideas and knowledge and hear other people's perspectives. A recent paper that we've published which is all about using photographs in therapy and I think this might be interesting to your listeners because this is an area that I got really excited about when I sat on a steering committee for a photo voice research project and the participants who'd taken part in this, sorry, people who'd taken part in
这项研究的人——照片之声研究使用照片来帮助人们讨论对他们重要的事情。这项研究着眼于严重精神疾病患者改善身体健康的障碍，参与者每周都会被赋予一个主题，去拍一些照片，然后把照片带回来在焦点小组中讨论。这项研究所需的目的是提取出主题。但我们发现的是，参与者实际上非常喜欢拍照，也非常喜欢分享照片。这作为一个也喜欢把照片作为交流手段的人来说，真的深深触动了我。所以，是的，我们刚刚发表了
this research, so the photo voice research uses photographs to help people discuss things that are important to them. This research was looking at barriers to improving physical health for people with severe mental illness and what the participants had done each week, they would be given a theme and they'd go and take some photographs and they'd bring them back and talk about this in the focus group. The purpose of that research was to pull out the themes. But what we found out was that the participants actually really loved taking the photographs and they really loved sharing photographs. And that really struck a chord with me as someone who also likes to share photographs as a means of communication, if you like. And so, yeah, we've just published this
这篇论文，这是杰米·巴罗（Jamie Barrow）博士的博士论文研究。我是共同导师，另一位是利兹临床心理学课程主任基拉·马斯特森（Kira Masterson）博士。所以，是的，我们研究了人们在辩证行为疗法（DBT）知情的小组中使用和分享照片的体验。如果有人感兴趣的话，那篇论文的链接在我的推特动态上。但我们只是想分享这些想法，你知道的，我们可以在治疗、心理健康干预中使用照片。你知道的，人们无论如何都在拍照，不是吗？人们一直在WhatsApp上与
paper, which was Dr. Jamie Barrow's doctoral thesis research. I was a co-supervisor together with Dr. Kira Masterson, who's the director of the Leeds Clinical Psychology course. And so, yeah, we were looking at people's experience of using and sharing photographs in a dialectical behavior therapy informed group. So the link to that is on my Twitter feed if anybody's interested. But just trying to share these ideas that, you know, we can use photographs in therapy, in mental health interventions. You know, people are taking photographs anyway, aren't they? People are sharing photographs with
其他人分享照片。所以让我们看看能否把这一点引入治疗中。有很多不同的方法可以做到这一点。所以在我们的论文中，我们探讨了主题、这样做的利弊。听起来太有趣了。而且，这只是作为一个现代人的一部分，你知道的，当我跟我的私人教练做私教课，或者我和一个朋友在一起什么的，你经常会掏出手机，对吧，去向别人展示和说明一些事情。我认为是时候把它引入治疗中了。这不是我以前真正考虑过的事情，但真的非常非常重要。
people all the time on WhatsApp. So let's see if we can bring this into therapy. And there's lots of different ways to do that. So within our paper, we looked at the themes, the pros and cons of doing that. That sounds so interesting. And it's, it's just part of being a modern human, you know, when I'm doing personal training sessions with my personal trainer, or I'm, you know, with a friend or something, you often reach for your phone, don't you to demonstrate and show people something. And I think it's time that was in therapy. It's not something that I've ever really thought about, but really, really important stuff.
如果你把链接发给我，我也会把它放在节目简介（show notes）里。当然，我也会在节目简介里链接你的所有社交媒体。但我非常喜欢的是，你也展示了即使在你获得资格之后，甚至当你开办私人诊所时，你仍然可以参与研究。
So if you share the link with me, I'll put that in the show notes as well. And obviously I'll link to all your socials in show notes as well. But I love that you're also demonstrating that you can still become involved in research even when you're qualified, even when you're in private practice as well.
所以感谢你向我们强调这一点。与你交谈非常荣幸，是的，祝你今天剩下的时间和目前从事的各项工作都一切顺利。谢谢你，玛丽安。能和你交谈非常荣幸。哦，与瑞秋博士交谈绝对是一大乐事。
So thank you for highlighting that to us. It's such a pleasure to speak with you and yeah, wishing you well with the rest of your day and the rest of the roles that you're engaged in at the moment. Thank you, Marianne. It's been a pleasure to speak to you. Oh, what an absolute pleasure to speak with Dr. Rachel.
我希望你觉得这和我与她现场聊天时一样有帮助。在镜头之外，我确实问过，他们会提供自助餐吗？当你开执行董事和非执行董事会议时，会提供午餐吗？答案是没有，没有。你知道我很喜欢自助餐。所以，是的，我最近去戈尔韦（Galway）为爱尔兰心理学协会做主题演讲时，我在会议结束后正匆忙离开，那些预订我的活动的人人非常好，在我离开的时候，他们正在吃一些水果，他们就问，能为你拿点什么吗？能为你拿点什么吗？你想吃根香蕉吗？我们有很多香蕉。我说，不用了，谢谢。我不是很喜欢香蕉。这是我不太吃的少数几种水果之一。我可以搭配一些冰淇淋或蛋奶冻吃。但，是的，我没法单独吃一整根香蕉。所以，是的，你在这个播客中了解到了关于我的各种随机信息，这就是其中之一。不管怎样，我希望你觉得这非常有用。如果你对未来的播客节目有任何想法，不要见外，一定要告诉我，来社交媒体上找我玩，与我连接。我到处都是Dr Marianne Trent。如果你在YouTube上观看这个节目，请务必点赞、订阅和评论。做所有这些事情。在社交媒体上与你的朋友分享你最喜欢的剧集。
I hope you found that as helpful as I did when I was chatting with her live. Off camera, I did ask, so do they give you, get a buffet? Do you get some lunch when you do your executive and non-executive meetings? No, no is the answer. And you do know that I do love a buffet. So yes, when I was in Galway recently for my keynote speech for the Irish Psychological Society, I was just dashing off after the meeting and the people that had booked me, who were lovely, as I was leaving, they were eating some fruit and they were like, can we get you anything? Can we get you anything? Do you want a banana? We've got lots of bananas. And I was like, I'm okay. Thank you. I'm not a banana fan. One of the few fruits I don't really eat. I can manage it with some ice cream or some custard. But yeah, I couldn't eat a whole banana by itself. um so yeah you learn random bits of information about me in this podcast that's one um anyway i hope you found it so useful um if you've got any ideas for future podcast episodes don't be a stranger do let me know come and hang out come and connect with me on socials i am dr marianne trent everywhere if you're watching this on YouTube, please do like, subscribe and comment. Do all those things. Share your favorite episode with your friends on socials.
我期待着在我们的下一期播客节目中与你叙旧，该节目将于周一上午6点开始播出。而且，对自己好一点。保重。听着这个播客，你就在获得资格的路上。这是玛丽安博士的“有志心理学家”（The Aspiring Psychologist）。我的名字叫亚娜（Yana），我是一名见习心理健康从业者。我读了《临床心理学家集体》（Clinical Psychologist Collective）这本书。我觉得里面所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的经历都非常有趣。到达那里有如此多不同的途径，这让我感到震惊，而且没有完美的途径可以成为一名临床心理学家。
And I'll look forward to catching up with you for our next episode of the podcast, which will be along from 6 a.m. on Monday. And, yeah, be kind to yourselves. Take care. this podcast at your side you'll be on your way to being qualified it's the aspiring psychologist with dr marianne my name's yana and i'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one.
这在某种程度上让我充满了信心，我不认为自己做错了，也减轻了给自己的压力。所以如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有些不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你开始读，你就不会放下这本书。目前这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。
And this kind of filled me with confidence that no, I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist, I definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay but trust me you will not put the book down once you start There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这让我充满了信心，知道我没有做错，也减轻了我自己的压力。所以，如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的，但相信我，一旦你开始读，你就不会放下这本书。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。